i always enjoy my chats with this man he
plays the role of negan in the walking
dead the show's currently in season 11
the final season
this current season is airing in three
parts the second and third parts airing
in the next calendar year uh 9 p.m
eastern sundays on amc a die-hard member
of the 12s
of the seattle seahawks jeffrey dean
morgan back here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line how
are you jeffrey hey rich
i'm good man good to hear you good to
speak with you as well yeah
i wish i i wish i could uh you know be
there with you for god's sake right back
at you for years now i know but hey but
at least we're we're we're moving
hopefully
closer
in the area code of the right direction
and just seeing fans back
you know yeah let's knock wood knock
wood on there
exactly um so but seeing fans back in in
seattle the 12s back in the building
um it was pretty cool to see uh did how
did you take in the uh the home opener
i watched it but um you know the
seahawks they called and invited me to
the game
um and i i would have loved to have gone
but i'm uh i'm one of those guys that's
still uh i'm being real careful still
yeah doing my part uh it makes me
nervous as great as it was seeing the
fans there um
although you know we [ __ ] sorry
no i hear you
i hear you
well i i started the show by saying
derek henry is the football lucille you
know
pretty much oh my god you know right
and they kept swinging it he's saving
grace he's on my fantasy team
[Applause]
because you as a seahawk fan be like
enough already but you as the fantasy
fan you're like this is the greatest
thing ever that they keep swinging that
back i would much rather be losing my
fantasies than having the seahawks win
but uh yeah he killed us that that
second half was
was brutal
um i'm still i'm still lamenting all of
it um you know i have a tendency to
rerun the game in my brain and and that
was a that was a long night that night
yeah i know it i don't know if you're
aware there was a statistic
um
that would have been a first had the
seahawks won
that there's never been a division that
started all two-and-oh
and not only that yeah there's never
been a difference
yeah i did know that and
and that's the thing with this division
we you can't afford to lose i mean you
just you just can't especially a
non-division game
um
it hurt it hurt and we knew going in
i mean i can look at the damn schedule i
i can see who everybody's playing and it
didn't look good and it doesn't look
great this weekend with the exception of
one i think maybe tight game but
and ours and you know the seahawks they
can't they can't uh they don't step on
the throat they can't do it
yeah i'm saying that's hoping to inspire
them no
no i i know it's just that there there
does i i don't know that that that was a
game
for the lack of a better phrase back in
the day
that would be a wrap 30 to 16 at home is
a wrap that's a wrap like that you have
no chance it's something you know uh
that you know anytime we have a 14 point
lead
at halftime much less the fourth quarter
we were you know
we haven't ever lost in the pete carroll
era which has been a while um this has
and at home home opener we'd won 13 in a
row
uh
so it was that's
a hit i'm not going to lie i'm not going
to try to sugarcoat it and say oh we're
going to be okay because i don't know
jeffrey dean morgan here on the rich
eisen show and as you point out though
you're right i mean look you gotta keep
winning games certainly since arizona
goes to tennessee
and they put their their foot down on
top of derek henry and never let him off
and then the titans go to your house and
um he just goes off in the second half
just runs right through so you can't
even sit here and say well you tell them
to he's 56 yards i think in the in the
first half that was it you know looking
okay
uh
but you know
oh god i just i i'm
bobby wagner got 20 solos incredible in
that game
and
incredible and i you know he's the
greatest but that shouldn't happen
either i don't think that's a great stat
um where's the rest of our defense
um
we'll see i'm nervous about this year
and i was going in and i am now and
we'll see how shane waldron works out i
thought the first game
um looked a lot better than the second
game i thought i thought last week we
kind of fell into the trap of of last
year um
[Music]
oh man rich i don't know i know i'm
nervous as hell though i know certainly
since the minnesota team coming up next
they're they're on two their backs are
against the proverbial wall and they're
not bad i mean they're they the owen too
isn't isn't a good uh
kind of representation of who they are
um and i expect them to be really good
at home this camp jeffrey dean morgan
here on the rich eisenhower is not
getting easier who else is on your
fantasy team after that we're playing
you know cut two division games and
i mean like three games in a row that
are just sweaty that i are toss-up games
who else is on your fantasy team
i assume you won uh i got justin herbert
playing quarterback
i got lockett which has been awesome
he's been on fire
um
i got the niners defense
um well you must have won last week
trading some people back and forth i'm
2-0 so far in my fantasy league which is
uh work uh the walking dead fantasy
league i was about to ask you um who
else is in it from the show that we
would know uh you've got some of the
cast some of the crew
um
the crew guys are the ones that make me
nervous they're the cast i feel like i i
got a good grip on um
seth who plays eugene i played the he's
he's who i got this week
um
kari who's king ezekiel i beat him week
one
and it but it's the crew guys and a
couple of the crew gals that are
actually
like making the point
okay they're the smart ones all right so
what's what's your team name since this
is a walking dead fantasy league well it
was uh i think we're in a yahoo league
and it's whatever they gave me so it's
jeffrey d morgan's nice team
you could
i don't know anything about computers
and i've tried to change it like a
hundred times and i can't do it yes so
it's just history
jeffrey dean morgan's nice team so
negan's team is jeffrey morgan's 19
where jeffrey d morgan's really nice
team and they assigned these to me at
the beginning of the year and i can't
figure out how to make it something
cooler everybody else has got cooler
names except for me so i
oh my gosh they won't help me they're
like no dude you're just gonna stay
brockman we gotta help him out what have
you gotta do here yeah so jeffrey in
yahoo under my team there's a little
subset that says roster watch list team
log edit team info and if you go to edit
team info you can change your name under
there there you go edit team info
so my my team and go to edit yeah edit
team info
and then
you can give yourself an avatar you can
change your team name you can do all
that your your your name
your neighbor your your neighbor paul
jeffrey your neighbor paul rudd um calls
into our show every year and helps us
decide our team name because we'll just
say lines throughout the whole year that
we think could be a funny team name we
write him down and then he chooses uh he
chose uh our winning one was walking
ibuprofen
he chose that one uh which i think was
in reference to ben roethlisberger we
call him walking ibuprofen
and then
and then for some reason the
conversation was about uh the the the
movie fatal attraction and a fan called
in
and uh he called in and called glenn
close glenn what's her nuts
um
so
you can have that one paul did discarded
that one if you were bad if you kind of
like glenn what's or not but please
we all do
that would make us so happy it's a solid
name and it seems very much within my
character realm to say you know glenn
what's or not
you okay and that seems like a negan
thing to say yes so and you could or so
it could be the avatar could be you with
lucille from way back in the day or
whatever from glenn what's your nuts's
career you could that could be the
avatar glenn what's your nuts i don't
know if an avatar can even speak to that
name i think that nate stands alone
there you go so we've given you the name
and but most importantly the road the
road map it's it's gonna be on my thing
within 10 minutes of us hanging out
fantastic and then we've given you the
road map on how to actually change this
thing and you could call back if you
need any more instructions we'll walk
you through it
what's your nuts
they're going to think glenn the who i
bashed in the hand yeah
yes
yes that could be the glenn what's or
nuts
that's so great where it was right there
that was the fan calling in
a glenn watson okay very good um so
i'm gonna try to explain how i got this
name and no one's gonna buy it that's
brutal you're harsh it's great i love it
let them let them you know soak in on
that one you know
i love it
the walking dead currently in season 11
what can you tell
fans about what's to come give me
something you got something a little
nugget yeah i think you touched on it
it's the last season and so
you know trying to wrap up
an 11-year program that has been kind of
such a
iconic show for so long um i don't know
how easy the task at is for our
our writers and and the people well
above my pay grade um
and i don't know where they're going and
everything's kind of a surprise to me
every script is something new
um so we will see
i'm hoping that negan is going to
survive
uh and continue sort of his road to
redemption okay um but i have a feeling
it's never going to be that easy
once i say glenn what's or not
we'll just drop that into
decide to change whatever the hell they
were thinking so you're not all in the
can then this is not all shot out and
being strung out over the middle of
shooting now okay uh we've
we've been shooting uh since the end of
january and we shoot until march of next
year
okay so you don't know how this is what
how this is being wrapped i don't do
they know do they know that the writers
and the writers
say they know i don't know that i
believe them um
but they they say the show runner and
the writers say they know um
i have no idea i have asked and they're
not giving me anything else all right
you know
so then let's let's use this platform
then uh
how do you want negan to finish up what
would you want like if you had your
druthers playing this character you know
one of two ways
uh either kind of walking off into the
sunset solo
or going down swinging you know um
and i don't who i'm swinging on i don't
think even matters but i i wouldn't
be opposed to negan just
crashing the party and ending strong and
taking out everybody
so
are you saying let negan cook is that
what you're using is it what you're
saying right now
that's exactly right
that is exactly right let negan cook and
there's the new t-shirt yeah
tweet that out right now
the owner of glenn watts or nuts says
let negan cook that's what he's saying
right now
yeah time to unleash him
that's what i'm i'm just wondering if
you could go into the writer's room and
just say let negan cook because you were
i mean look if you really want to go
full football and algae like aaron
rodgers you should have a say right you
should have a say in how your character
finishes up his career on the walking
dead i i would love to um
and obviously we've deviated enough from
the comics although in the comics negan
does
survive okay um
i you know no one knows well i don't
know if our ending will coincide with
how the comics ended because it's kind
of so different
uh you know we've lost
you know rick and carl and michonne some
of the big characters that survived in
the comics are no longer
with us
at this point so
so it'll be interesting to see where we
go
uh and how how we end this um
i i i just i think the fans will dig it
and that's kind of the key
it sure is no question about it you can
cook no fans will really like it there
you go let negan cook at jd morgan on
twitter at jeffrey dean morgan on
instagram shows currently in season 11
final season uh second and third
uh parts of season 11 will air next year
they're being shot as we speak walking
dead airing sundays at 9 00 pm eastern
on amc so
that's the nuts and bolts of the
promotion but let's really focus on
what's most important
what is it again what has he got to do
he's got to go to the the edit team
settings on what is it again from my
team and then down to edit team info
let's go to my team and then the edit
settings
something or other glenn watts or nuts
glenn watts her nuts yeah that's it
glenn what's your name you go within
five minutes you're welcome
there you go you're welcome jeffrey
don't even say thank you it's already
understood
rich and paul and crew you got it you
take care jeffrey dean morgan everybody
from the walking dead he says he wants
negan to cook let negan cook i think i
think megan is going to cook
he wants to go down swinging and as he
said it doesn't matter who he's swinging
at
love it
are we honest
uh that's how derek henry operated in
the second half
okay rich uh jeffrey dean morgan a man
of his word less than five minutes
just tweeted at us
glenn what's her name
[Music]
fantastic now do we reach back to him
and say glenn close is spelled with two
wins that's right
but glenn
from walking dead is one perfect perfect
just perfect
perfect
so now our mentions are just filled with
walking dead fans thinking that he's
trolling the dude that he killed on the
show
but we knew that was going to happen
right
[Laughter]
pretty amazing oh this is amazing great
this is really you know i'll be honest
with you we've been on the air almost
seven full years this is one of our
finest moments people helping people
rich people helping people rich eisen
show consulting that's it's consulting
you make it so better today we earned
our money can we get our business cards
and i'm talking about business cards
that would make patrick bateman blush
that's what we need okay
a nice bone nice bone with the razor
and the little uh water yeah got a
little watermelon
clothing let me do it you make your life
better
we have to use this photo photo
of us as the uh yes
i love it
look whenever if you need casting help
you have so much chest
well at spoiler alert i really have that
much chest there that's perfect perfect
and i look like that in a suit it's
perfect casting riots consulting perfect
casting
we came out with the what should be the
new cast of the uh remake of the
bodyguard if you need a general manager
or coaching help don't spend tens of
thousands of dollars a hundred thousand
dollars just no no a few thousand no no
we don't come in expensively yeah but we
ain't free either fine piece of tiffany
if you need help you know changing your
team name on your fantasy side you just
help them navi literally this guy could
not feel he couldn't figure it out he
couldn't navigate the yahoo interface we
told him and now boom
we land the plane like sully glenn these
are nuts we do
just call adam in the back seagull hits
your engine we land
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here